foreign
hey you guys and welcome back once again
to flickers of fear my little movie
review Series so not too long before I'm
recording this which you know in case
you were wondering is early November of
2022
uh shutter actually added a couple of
Lucio full cheese I guess less
celebrated movies
um including Enigma from 1987 uh demonia
from 1990. and the movie that we're
going to be talking about today which is
called Manhattan baby and it came out in
1982. now this movie was also released
under the titles eye of the evil dead
and the possessed I believe that was the
UK title now its original title like the
Scripps original title was the evil eye
which frankly makes a lot more sense
than Manhattan baby does but we'll get
into that in a minute now I had seen all
of these movies uh Manhattan baby Enigma
and demonia at some point uh you know
one time or another but my last viewings
of them were at least 20 years ago
probably more and I couldn't really
remember a single thing about any of
them so I kind of got curious and I was
like well you know I'm gonna take
another Gander at these and see what the
hell's going on so I thought I'd start
with the earliest one which of course is
Manhattan baby now I'm going to say
watching it again uh I could totally
understand why Manhattan baby didn't
really stick with me like you know after
seeing it so many years ago it's
definitely not among fochie's best films
and I'm gonna say that uh later on like
both him and the screenwriter who's
dardano sashetti who he worked with a
lot uh they later they didn't like
totally disown it but kind of you know
what I mean like Lucio folgy in
particular called it quote unquote
terrible and actually pointed to it as
the reason that after this he never
worked again with his you know uh
producer that had worked with him on a
lot of his films like Fabricio uh
d'angelis he had actually worked with
him on zombie
um the Beyond house by the cemetery in
New York Ripper I think and he's like
this after this it was like no more they
didn't work together again after this
part of the problem it seemed like was
that the original concept of the film
was supposed to be like I guess a more
big budget or at least big budget for
for a full G movie
um kind of like more of a paranormal
Extravaganza type thing like maybe more
along the lines of poltergeist or
something like that
um and it was going to have a focus like
I said more in paranormal or occult
themes rather than the gore and you know
more slasher type uh stuff that he'd
been known for prior but then maybe
because
um you know full cheese and deangelis's
previous movie like the New York Ripper
didn't maybe perform as well as expected
uh the budget for Manhattan baby was
sliced in half I believe he was first
gonna get 800 million Lira and then he
only got 400 million Lira I'm not really
sure what the exchange rate was back
then or what the American equivalent of
that would be but I'm gonna say that uh
the lack of funds to realize the vision
of the story as it was written is pretty
evident as you watch this movie so
meanwhile I don't feel like Manhattan
baby is an awful film
I will admit that it was kind of a slog
to sit through and it's not really even
that long I think it's only an hour and
28 minutes or something like that I mean
it is glacially paced uh it borders on
narratively incoherent like it doesn't
really make a whole hell of a lot of
sense and has a bunch of very strangely
lifeless acting performances with only a
couple of exceptions I mean there are
some really interesting ideas in here
but a lot of them not gonna lie were
swiped from other better movies
including some of volchi's own prior
movies like for example in this movie we
have a mysterious woman who's wearing
the same kind of like all-white contact
lenses as Emily from the Beyond and
Manhattan baby also uses the that exact
same like World tinkling uh discordant
like piano tune that was in the Beyond
it's the exact same piece of music and
it's used here as well we also have an
appearance here from Giovanni frezza who
of course played Bob the iconic
character in 1981's uh the house by the
cemetery thankfully he's dubbed by
someone else in this because I kind of
feel like that's why everybody remembers
him mostly from house by the cemetery
was that terrible dubbing but it's like
somebody else dubs him in this one and
on top of that this movie also homages
lots of other films like Rosemary's Baby
uh in the fact that it's called
Manhattan baby as an homage to
Rosemary's Baby also there's a character
in this whose name is Adrian Marcato
which was also a reference to Rosemary's
Baby this also takes some [ __ ] from The
Exorcist in that it's focused on a young
girl who's possessed by an evil spirit
that latched on to her I guess after
like an archaeological Expedition type
of thing like in the desert
and also a pretty blatant homage to the
birds which uh occurs in the absolutely
bat [ __ ] or no I guess I should probably
say bird [ __ ] the bird [ __ ] final
sequence which I'll get into a little
bit in a minute
also because it's kind of focused around
egyptology and specifically on like an
eight like an evil ancient Egyptian
curse of some kind that seemingly
possesses the daughter of an
archaeologist you could also say that
Manhattan baby was very heavily
influenced by maybe the 1971 Hammer
movie blood from the mummy's tomb which
matter of fact was actually in turn
based Loosely based uh on the 1903 novel
by Bram Stoker which is called the jewel
of seven stars so story wise in
Manhattan baby you got uh the American
actor Christopher Connolly who actually
was best known for being on Peyton Place
back in the 1960s
um he stars as the aforementioned
archaeologist whose name is Professor
George hacker now he's in Egypt working
like on a working holiday I guess uh and
he's accompanied by his wife Emily who's
played by Laura Lindsay and their
nine-year-old daughter Susie who's
played by brigitta bacoli
now their younger son Tommy who is you
know Bob from house by the cemetery uh
has actually stayed home back in New
York uh looked after by the family's au
pair very fancy uh Jamie Lee and Jamie
Lee is actually played by uh China de
Ponte and she was also a New York Ripper
and she was also in the Lum the lumberto
Baba movie like from 1984 called monster
shark which maybe if you're an MST fan
like I am you probably know better as
devil fish that's the same movie and I
recognized her immediately from uh from
that so during this Expedition or
whatever it is uh George the
archaeologist comes across this
unexplored tomb that's kind of rigged
with booby tracks booby traps like very
much like Indiana Jones like Lara Croft
kind of situation uh including a pit of
spikes that kills one of his colleagues
and some weird blue laser beams that
shoot George in the eyes and blind him
now while all that is going on uh Emily
is kind of over here at some other place
like taking photos is at another site
and she leaves their daughter Susie
alone for a few minutes for whatever
reason uh at which point this creepy old
woman with the completely white eyes
like Emily from the Beyond uh gives the
little girl an amulet and then
mysteriously vanishes so they go back to
New York and George is understandably
like kind of grumpy about this whole
loss of vision thing although the doctor
is like pretty sure it's just temporary
and it should you should regain your
site like within the year but it turns
out that he gets it back sooner than
that because there's like another zap
from a blue laser beam like in their
house somehow and it restores his vision
so it almost kind of seems as though
whatever it was that was in that
Egyptian tomb didn't want him to see
something that was in there I mean
that's kind of what I thought but don't
get too excited about this little
mystery because it doesn't really end up
factoring into anything like as The
Story Goes forward and really at any at
any rate like the blindness didn't
really work as intended if that's indeed
what the intention was because George
actually remembers what he saw on the
tomb like well enough to describe it to
another colleague friend of his named
Weiler
so Emily meanwhile the wife she's also a
journalist now she has this insufferable
co-worker named Luke who thankfully is
only in a couple of scenes he's actually
played by uh Carlo de Mayo mayo or
something who was in city of the Living
Dead and the house by the cemetery uh
he's kind of one of those guys he's
always doing like wacky things like look
I'm just sitting at my desk with Groucho
with a Groucho nose on or you know I
have those glasses on where the eyeballs
come off on Springs and stuff like that
I'm so zany waka waka it was like that
kind of thing so one day while at work
Emily gets a phone call from the au pair
Jamie Lee uh that the kids are locked in
their room and she can't get them out so
Emily and Luke go to you know Emily's
house like where the kids are I don't
know why she felt the need to take Luke
with her but whatever
um so they get there and Luke being
dorky again is like I'll go I'm gonna
open it I'll show you like the door will
open like really really easily so he
marches up the stores the stairs and
indeed he does open the door the bedroom
door like really easily but subsequently
disappears into some kind of portal like
made up of this blue light now Emily
doesn't see this because it happens like
up at the top of the stairs
so after a few minutes she goes up there
and she sees the doors open but she
can't find Luke anywhere she's like what
the [ __ ] like he just disappeared you
know
um but basically she just attributes
this Vanishing act to his you know his
ability he's like the fact that he does
practical jokes all the time I'm like
okay and so then he didn't like even
show up at work and he just like never
came back so okay yeah it's a pretty
good practical joke I guess uh but we as
the audience know that he's absolutely
not coming back because we see that he's
somehow through this portal like been
transported to the Egyptian desert it
looks like where he has presumably like
perished from dehydration so we don't
know how long he's been there so it
turns out you see that the amulet that
Susie has that the lady in Egypt gave
her is cursed somehow like ostensibly by
a demon or something named have new
Menor I think is how you pronounce it
um and this amulet essentially like
allows people to travel to another
dimension tension so Susie and Tommy go
on several of these what they call
voyages though these Journeys that
they're going on are never shown they
basically are just kind of like oh we
came back oh yeah we went on a voyage
you know what I mean but they don't you
know they didn't have the budget to like
show anything honestly it was never
really all that clear to me like whether
the kids could go anywhere they wanted
or if they always went to the same place
like they went to the ancient Egypt
Dimension I kind of suspect that it's
the latter because sometimes in the
course of the story it does kind of seem
like the um ancient Egyptian Dimension
like overlaps maybe like with this
Dimension because like for example like
on a couple of occasions like the
Florida on the kit of the kids bedroom
is like occasionally covered with sand
and then later on they do like lab
analysis of the sand and they're like
hey this is from the Nile Delta or
whatever but it's never like explicitly
stated so I'm guessing you can just kind
of go between these two places now at
some point uh the au pair Jamie Lee She
disappears as well and Tommy tells his
parents it's that she also went on a
voyage and hasn't come back yet later on
George's colleague Wyler the guy he told
about the tomb earlier uh gets killed in
his office by a cobra so there's that
there's also the very small matter of a
Polaroid picture that Jamie Lee took of
Susie the little girl in Central Park
and initially they think that um the
film was [ __ ] up or something like
that because the picture just comes out
completely washed out like he can't see
anything but then so they just kind of
like Chuck It On The Ground which litter
bugs okay you know they don't see it but
it later like develops into an image
that has like the park normal in the
background but then in the instead of
Susie in the foreground is like the
amulet really big
so a woman finds this photo calls this
antique dealer named Adrian Marcato
about it and then writes his name on the
back of the picture and for some reason
like puts it in an envelope and then
tosses it to Emily like From A Balcony
like while Emily is like walking down
the street so then after this like Susie
starts kind of like fainting all the
time and like looking kind of ill
there's like more weird blue light kind
of anomalous effects and things like
that and even though George and Emily
are you know pretty skeptical of the
Paranormal they eventually track down
Adrian Marcato and see if he can give
them any information or insight as to
like what's going on
so he tells them about this amulet and
the evil stone that sort of like resides
within it I guess and he tells them that
their daughter has essentially like
absorbed the evil or absorbed this bad
energy or whatever now they don't
believe him at first like who would uh
but then they find the amulet hidden in
Susie's desk drawer like protected by a
little black scorpion and it so happens
that the moment that they find it they
get a phone call telling them about
Weiler like his weird death like how he
got killed by a cobra
um and that kind of makes it more makes
them more willing to like accept that
there's something Supernatural going on
I guess but they still take Susie to the
hospital to get checked out
uh in another kind of homage to The
Exorcist I guess uh also one of the
doctors is played by Lucio fulchi
because you know how um you know how he
likes to like turn up in cameos like in
his own in his own movies so he gets
like a couple minutes of screen time
where he's just sitting there like
baffled and like shaking his head like
that which I thought was really funny so
at the hospital they find out this
little girl's x-rays like show that
there's like a shadow of a cobra like
inside her body and I'm just like okay
also at one point they have her in the
bed and she's all hooked up to like all
these like monitors on her head and
whatnot for some reason and it seems
like she kind of dies temporarily at
least judging from the heart monitor
which kind of like flatlines but like
the oddly hilarious thing is that
there's no like when the girl flat lines
there's no alarm or anything like that
like to alert hospital staff like hey
somebody's dying you might want to come
and like try to revive him or whatever
and like while all that's going on look
at flat lines and her mom is just kind
of like standing there looking at her
blankly and like looking at the Monitor
and looking at her I'm like um are you
gonna call somebody or not Potter it was
just like very very weird I mean Susie
does eventually revive because Marcato
is doing some [ __ ] like in his own place
that's kind of like sorting everything
out I guess but the lack of reaction on
the part of the mom is like really
really bizarre which I think that's one
of the things that I meant when I said
the acting performances were kind of
like lifeless because she's just like
you would think she would be like
flipping out I mean that's her daughter
and it's like she's dying oh my God like
come help me Dr nurse blah blah blah
like that's what they would usually do
in movies too but she just kind of
stands there and goes
like look it back and forth like from
the looking back and forth from the girl
to the [ __ ] monitor I'm like it was
just so so weird so anyway like the
reason that Susie comes back I guess or
is revived is that Marcato is back in
his antique shop and he's I guess like
take taken the evil curse onto himself
thus which thereby like freeze Susie I
think I think that's what's going on
kind of hard to tell it was just kind of
like the because the scene like I said
they didn't have a lot of a lot of
budget so it's like they couldn't really
show him like battling with the demon or
anything like that so basically it's
just like a scene of like a close-up of
his eyes and like he's staring at the
amulet and like [ __ ] there's blue
light like in his face and he looks all
scared and then like it's all over you
know what I mean but then so yeah so
apparently like he took the curse on to
himself hey I saved your daughter you
know you're welcome but then all the
stuffed birds in his antique shop all
come to life and like Tippy hedger in
his ass leading to what is easily the
best bit of dialogue in the movie like
while this is happening like he's
getting packed to death by stuffed birds
he says you can take my life with
stuffed birds but you shall not have my
immortal Soul have new man or birds of
Darkness consume me and I just died
laughing at that point this is so so
funny I was like alrighty then uh
incidentally this scene here
is pretty much the only scene in the
movie that sort of recalls full cheese
like older Gore Classics you know I mean
like zombie and stuff like that and
really even by his standards like it's
still pretty restrained like it's not
really all that gross you didn't get
that much eye trauma it's almost kind of
like a little bit of teased eye trauma
because he's like the these kind of
pecking around the eyes but like not in
the eyes I don't know if they couldn't
afford to like do the full splinter in
the eyeball you know what I mean but
they don't do any of that uh really the
only other flash of Gore that occurs is
when Jamie Lee who like I said went on a
voyage and didn't come back and turns
out she was like behind the wall somehow
um but her kind of like Grody zombified
arm like pops out from a hole in the
wall and that's with you know some kind
of crap all over it but that's like
about it like as far as Gore goes so
George the archaeologist uh upon
marcato's advice we obviously gave him
advice before he died because he does
die
um he basically like takes the amulet
and Chucks it in the East River but
which supposedly like gets rid of the
curse but then there's like this little
brief epilogue and we see like that
white-eyed lady like in back in Egypt
like giving the same amulet or what
appears to be the same amulet to another
little girl so the curse continues I
guess I mean it's never really explained
like who this woman is why she's
specifically targeting young girls like
to give this amulet to like what is have
new Menorah like is he a demon what's
his ultimate goal I mean if his ultimate
goal is world domination I mean it's
gonna take a while if he just keeps
targeting one kid at a time with these
mystical Dimension hopping amulets that
he has but you know I don't know that's
I'm not a demon so I don't really know
maybe he's a slow and steady wins the
race kind of guy I'm not gonna like you
know get all up in his [ __ ] about it
because he knows what he's doing clearly
so anyway like I said I mean this isn't
a great film by any means I know that it
has its uh Defenders uh some people
really do like the kind of borderline
surrealistic tone to it and I guess like
fulchi's willingness to try something
conceptually different from what he'd
done before and honestly like this movie
almost seems like this kind of like
heralded the more
sci-fi and fantasy based direction that
he kind of explored in some of his later
work he did do like more slashers and
stuff like that like later on like as
the 80s progressed but he did do a lot
of more sci-fi sword and sandal type
stuff like uh in the 80s and this is
kind of like the first little hint of
that I guess now I do like the idea of
weaving kind of an Egyptian curse
narrative and a parapsychological kind
of angle like into a story which is set
in modern day New York but you know the
low budget and uh you know really really
didn't help and also the lack of a
cohesively explained mythology I kind of
feel like that really shot this one in
the dick because you know it's one thing
if you if you're writing a story where
you have like a supernatural force or a
supernatural demon or something like
that it has to have rules you have to
know what it can do what it can't do
like what are its weaknesses what are
its powers and stuff like that and it
seems like that was never really
established with any certainty so it
almost seemed like I don't know it just
seemed kind of half-assed because I was
just like well what what is the what is
the end goal like what is the end game
like for this demon or whatever it is
like why you know why are we targeting
these specific people like what you know
what I mean what what is the outcome
supposed to be and like you didn't
really know like exactly what the
parameters like of the powers were and
like the going between Dimensions or why
it had that or anything like that so it
just seemed like they didn't really like
think through you know uh kind of a
structure around like the Paranormal
thing that they had happening which you
do have to do maybe even more than if
you're doing something like realistic
because everybody has to understand
because this is a supernatural thing or
a thing that doesn't exist you have to
like make it pretty clear like what the
rules are and then you have to adhere to
those and I feel like the movie didn't
really do that now if you're really into
Lucio volci's movies and you haven't
seen this one for whatever reason
um I'd recommend that you watch it just
like for completion's sake but anybody
like not familiar with his work would
probably just be completely baffled and
or completely bored by it so I wouldn't
recommend it
um and even for full Chi fans this is
usually like ranks among his lowest like
I said it's not terrible but it's not
really all that great I didn't find it
like laughably bad but it is like it you
know it it was real slow and it was just
kind of real hard to sit through because
it just like wasn't clear exactly like
what was going on all the time and you
could tell that they had like a much
bigger idea that really had to be hemmed
in by you know them losing like half of
the budget
um so maybe if this had had the original
budget it would have like made more
sense and they could have like put more
stuff in it but you know as it was this
was the movie that we got and like I
said full she didn't really like it and
disowned it a little bit later on so let
me know if you have seen this movie and
if you did what you thought about it in
the comments and that will do it for
this flickers of fear I'll see you guys
again on the next one bye